all right we are here talking about
trying to make our long-standing
internal documentation tools available
to people more generally so
ah
let's talk about successes we've already
have and I mean first of all maybe we
can just bring up the existing document
joy and airplane cockpit um and let's
talk about okay first question
and I assume we have function repository
people here yes yes yeah okay so to my
mind this is quite successful what we've
done here two other people agree with
that
I mean this tools collection here to
other people hear me if your list of
tools is small enough that it can be
condensed onto a tool bar then sure yes
it's it's when it gets bigger than that
or you need anything more complex that
it the tool bar becomes not enough fair
enough
but okay but I mean so starting with the
tool bar seems like a good thing yeah
you could certainly have a toolbar that
do tear off a pallet if you need it my
own think we even talked about that for
this but maybe it was unrequired um when
there are tools whose scope might not be
local to just one notebook you know
there's that kind of issue too right
so this has the same type of thing here
you
I wouldn't call it subscribe to variable
subscripts etc and have it be a pulldown
which can do various things I would
suggest anyway we had discussed leaving
it off for data entirely at one point
but it survived ok does anybody know
what the status of the standard toolbar
for all notebooks is that presumably is
not in 12 1 or I would have seen it's
not in 12 1 and it's the we have a base
expect for it but we don't have a design
for it and you should get this NOAA
could to work on that it's this kind of
thing well I mean but on the graphic
design because that's the main thing
that we're missing right now I think it
needs
ok so graphic design has Jeremy looked
at it I don't know but it's in Billy's
queue but Billy's queue is pretty large
from what we understand so why don't
know who's who's Pia is part of being
that yeah so he should talk to Jeremy
about it because it seems like it's kind
of an important thing ok is it
conceivable for 12-1 or is it hopeless
hopeless for 12-1 ok no there's no
there's no wait we haven't even begun
implementation for it so no way ok um ok
what is this so obviously this is is not
designed or anything that what this is
what we're doing for version one of
these authoring tools is we are taking
the front end the interface the palette
that you see in workbench currently
which some people in live stream may be
familiar with and updating the back end
code and making a few adjustments as a
palette is necessary um obviously the
design I think what's our target here so
our target is to let people build pages
which can be deployed to the web and
deployed in a product is that classic
tackle it yeah and and yeah yeah that's
right
let's be very specific about the target
ok because the thing has to hang off
something in other words what are we
imagining so somebody builds bunch of
pages right they bill
function pages they build guide pages
but it's like where does the tree where
where is the root of the tree so to
speak where is it where does it hang
from are they deploying that for example
in the cloud to a specific URL and then
they have a whole tree of stuff hanging
off that URL or what well the no
discussion of these external documents
active documentation tools would be
complete without talking about the
Pacolet repository which is how these
are intended to be used primarily so
people are writing this documentation to
be to document their Pacolet and it
would be distributed with their Pacolet
perhaps not that I don't think that's an
adequate answer I don't think that's
adequate I don't think that's right I
think that people want things which are
on the web you know visible on the web
independent of whether somebody has the
packet or not well sure and and that's
what I was going to say next you know I
assumed the packet repository will have
some web presence and you know so you're
looking at the you know maybe maybe each
packet has a landing page and that
landing page could very well be a guy
page okay so let's be specific here I
mean let's just as the function
repository so let's look at what the
function repository does okay you build
one page per function and when you
deploy it
that becomes a cloud page with a URL
that you can either have privately or
you push it into the public one right I
believe you can also create a local page
if you can't you yes you can you can
which is also useful right and so
presumably the goal of these
documentation tools is the exact same
thing right to have the same deployment
paths is that a fair statement and no I
don't think that's true
because or certainly not not completely
true because certainly people will want
you know their packets to have search
indices and appear in the documentation
Center like all other document okay so
that's that's another that's where the
tree lives that's that's how the root of
the tree gets attached
two other things which is indeed that
the topic I want it you know I think an
important topic for us to address right
so so what we're doing right now and
which you know is I think acceptable if
not wonderful is and again the problem
is okay this is this is a fundamental
problem of these kinds of things if if
you are the creator of a package of some
kind and you want to insert yourself
into someplace you know how do you like
like you've got four package authors and
they all want top slot and where they
get inserted in the document in the
route guide page of a user they're not
all gonna be have top slot well they're
not I don't think they're going to
appear in the top slot packages right
now we have this crazy thing which by
the way is broken as we can see here um
right right now we have this by the way
note this is broken there's somebody
taking notes of that yeah okay so this
is if they have a properly built Pacolet
right then they can select something and
hit f1 or they can do question mark on
the symbol and it'll take them right to
its recipes right I understand that but
I want to know where is the root of the
tree attached yeah well and as I've
pointed out in a previous meeting I mean
I think the you know the execution of
this thing right now is is wanting but
the concept is not broken
okay so right now it's an alphabetical
list of installed add-ons right well we
had a really nice version of this that
we tone down to this boring style which
was a set of icons much more visual and
interesting okay
well we took we just D toned that ten
years ago to this you know rather okay
okay so Roger that that implies right
that when you you
when you provide a packet for planting
so to speak
hmm then you have to have a certain kit
like an icon and like a dis exactly and
so on yeah yeah exactly the kind of page
that we have now developed well with the
function repository and so on yeah yeah
exactly
okay so okay so the the question is in
what garden do these things get planted
right so one garden is this installed
add-ons link from the root guide page
another one is the pallets right which
are right now I mean I have no idea what
all of this stuff is right this is right
now again an alphabetical list of
pallets right yeah and you see you have
both you've got docu tools listed in
your add-ons because it is an add-on and
you've got a palette related to it that
displays in this menu that's how our
add-ons work okay so let's talk about
that for a second do we believe that we
should standardize on you know that what
would happen is that a pack Lata's a
name and that that name for example
becomes a submenu and by default becomes
a submenu in palettes well so many
packets only have one pallet or maybe
two it's a little weird to have a zoo of
sub menus each of which have only one or
two items fine I mean it's also worth
noting that many pack looks have zero
palettes yeah I was gonna but if it's
zero the case is trivial you just don't
don't put anything there I'm more
worried about the one into Paulo case
well I think one is fine you just have
the you know the name in the man and and
by the way you can choose you know this
is a thing you can do and it's document
on how to do this you can choose to you
know to have sub menus you can choose to
you know position things differently and
if you do it'll throw de limiters around
your stuff you know that's the only
reason that all those things are
aggregated is because all the people who
exactly you know what I don't think we
want to get people that much choice I
think we need to choose something that
will work
well and have that be the way it works
because let me just enumerate the cases
I mean okay one case that we care about
is people building essentially
standalone app systems right where
somebody is using Wolfram language but
fundamentally they're building a
standalone thing that's going to sing
and dance on its own where we just
happen to be the enabling technology
okay
those things we are really not providing
for I mean okay that's one level the
other level is people are fundamentally
using you know wool from one or
something and they've just got a bunch
of things installed and they are you
know making use of those installations
as appropriate so to speak and I think
that second case is the one that we're
primarily addressing right now there's a
separate issue of how we do the pure
standalone because then pure standalone
mode people are gonna want it to come up
with their padlet you know loaded and
whatever the start page of their packet
is I mean you know for the levels stand
alone that I think that you're talking
about it's not clear to me that this is
the sort of thing that one would
typically distribute through you know
what our concept of the Packer posit or
II know we wouldn't I don't you know
because this is a you know this is a
packet that you know wants to have
things to itself and yeah and if you
have to such packets you're gonna run it
Scopus hope so I mean look I think the
level what we should be doing is this we
should be providing for the ability to
make standalone apps okay it's its own
thing it's a developer story you make
your own you know it's it's your whole
own world when you get one of those and
and we can have a marketplace for
distributing those but fundamentally you
get one of those and potentially it
comes with its own copy of all from
engine etc etc etc makes sense well it
doesn't make sense that it all works now
I mean people are all currently doing
less and we've done it before
I know but okay so we need a kit for
making standalone apps that's one thing
then we need the standard way of
creating and installing packets for
people who are using our generic
broad spectrum tools like well from one
well well I mean and that's what I
thought was in part the purpose of this
meeting it was to really deal with the
second case rather oh no no I agree it
is because I'm just I'm just in that
story of the second case is basically
the hyper architecture story because
that's what we're talking about there
but that is you know there's a separate
thing which is the the kit for making
standalone apps yeah I mean hyper
architecture I think encompasses the
stay alone app case only just only just
I mean I think it's more okay fair
enough it's an extension towards that
but I think we should separately imagine
a kit for um you know for doing that
okay Brian our lifestreams suggests
quite sensibly allowing tags will list
to be presented more than one way like
if you have a large number of these you
know you know have have something which
is more like a file browser I mean the
question is is the metaphor for this a
file browser and it probably should be
for this thing right the list of what
things you have installed why not have
it be a file browser well if I mean I'm
not sure I understand what I mean by
that is for example you've got these
things and you know you can sort them by
date you can sort them by this etc I see
and possibly I mean I don't think look I
don't think it's a short-term problem
that people will have so many of these
that they can't find them you know with
obvious crutch you know obvious ways of
arranging them I mean I think most
people will have between zero you know
some people many people have zero a
bunch of people will have one two or
three and well few people will have and
if you talk about finding documentation
and being able to organize the things
that you care about in documentation I
mean that's a problem
that you know can be solved independence
of this well that's that's an issue of
pinning pieces of documentation you can
yes
yes which we can absolutely solve yeah
but but I mean but I want something
which even if it isn't pinned because I
think most people won't pin it you know
is reasonable and I think look we just
need a better version of this page
possibly with some selectors - - you
know I wouldn't worry about that
initially this is put them in
alphabetical order
you know people let people game the
aardvark so to speak if they really care
about that that makes sense
no I feel like you were going a couple
different directions there but the last
thing you said I think I agree with I
mean not not that you know not that I
think that extra stuff is a bad idea
necessarily but you know I also like to
ship stuff - okay so so why don't we get
something where basically we will have a
packet a page which is a packet
definition notebook or something what
are we going to call that do we already
have such a thing there's the purple one
I demoed it live stream oh that's right
okay so that's can you show that again
please
give me ten minutes to get by local
system right okay well okay even a
screenshot be useful okay fine so then
we'll have you know Bob's purple page is
that purple page just while we're
waiting to see it as that basically Bob
is that basically a interface to a
packet input on M file yeah and it has
the buttons for linking different kinds
of document pages documentation pages
whether it's a symbol or a guide or what
well while we're waiting on Bob I had a
related question which is of course the
pellet is only 50% of the process right
because that's all well therefore
creating the source notebooks but we
also need a way to convert source
notebooks into the things that are ready
to go into the doc Center that was part
of the workbench documentation tools
what is the proposal here that there be
another packet that you install that you
used to build documentation or that's a
point of discussion and it's actually on
the agenda
you know it's built code distribution
it's right there the next section um so
I mean there are how I see it we've got
a couple options here that each have
some pros or cons um you know I already
have you know mucked around with letting
you build documentation pages from
source pages using an API there's
something that actually works now you
know it takes a little longer than if it
were local of course but you don't have
to mess with calling the right thing you
just this is really simple I don't
understand just like we have this deploy
button which has several different
options for where it deploys do I think
we should do the same thing here another
word what I mean honorable on a
page-by-page basis though or let's see
bob's thing in the world no no no I just
want to finish this thought okay so what
I think we should do okay so the
question is is it page by page I think
you should be able to preview it page by
page and many of the links won't work
because you'll probably have a very
cross link thing there yeah right so I
think there's a previewing function but
I think in terms of just build me a
version that works um the um sorry
um alright but I don't know that the
individual rough page is the right place
for that button yeah if we have some
sort of Pacolet exactly that's the thing
voting out to show so why doesn't where
do we let Bob down his thing now okay
all right so this is very similar the
body of it is very much like the
existing packet info dot M instead of
the template notebook like thing in the
function but the idea is that you would
be able to like pick your kind and these
are just nothing notebooks but the idea
is that this would be something like the
function repository in notebook where
you couldn't put usage messages and
details and options and examples well
would that is saving these notebooks
you're creating so my so if you notice
this thing popped up obviously this one
be the user facing design but right my
idea was and if you haven't deployed
anywhere these notebooks are just
sitting here in memory if you if you
close them it's a bad idea we can warn
you well if you try to close them that
you shouldn't but then when you deploy
them they'll all get bundled up I don't
think that's a good idea people want to
people that typing a little stuff they
want to save save save save save all
right so if you want to do that you
there instead of this you can do one of
these guys and you could say add doc
page in there
why not others why not when you start
one of these up why don't you put it in
the local object store why did you point
it to the local object store when you
say create documentation why doesn't it
create a directory in the local object
store I don't I mean why isn't the
answer that you know this goes wherever
right it creates a tree wherever I mean
I suppose your little page here isn't
saved but why doesn't wherever that
thing is saved it creates a proper you
know path that I default site I mean
that is the idea but that notion of
wherever it is saved isn't determined
until you use this guy in the like
function repository and all that
resource at fixed in this idea of
saving based on where one notebook has
saved the other ones follow seems kind
of fraught to me it seems easier to me
that when you create one of these packet
resource definition notebooks that the
thing starts building well look okay we
could we could do that it'd be and
they'd be fine and then when you deploy
it it copies them all to a different
location where it's like a snapshot and
it's deployed and fixed I mean right so
let's make sense okay so I'm going to do
something I never thought I'd do but
which is actually point point out
something good about docu tools right
but docu tools in has a mode which I
have on by default which right when you
create a new page it asks you for the
symbol name and it creates it and saves
it immediately to the right place why
don't I have this mode really really
that's possible how do you do that you
you click the new page interactive
button at the bottom of the F tab and I
I don't you have to set up your CVS
checkout first but yeah when you do that
you fill it out and it saves it into
your CVS checkout you need you have to
scroll because of yeah I don't know why
scrolled on by default and why why new
page interactive isn't on by default
right and let's add the fact that not
only places it in the right place it
also fills out some of the metadata on
the top which is as well very much based
on which you fill out uh sorry clicking
a button doesn't do anything for me I
set because I don't have it set up
correctly there's well there's no
visible it's not like it shows selected
you know it's that grey on grey if
you've clicked it once it did toggle it
on but you have to you do have to set up
your CVS directory which it looks like
Bob didn't do that's why he's got that
ah I see it now okay I'm gonna turn this
on on all my computer's thank you
and what that thing does I think it
maybe may exist confusion here is
illustrative of the fact that our docu
tools is not ready to be exposed
even-steven it is on by default for you
right there are certain behaviors that
Stephen gets by default how did you get
a balloon version 12 icon it I went in
and modified the icon okay so I can tell
the difference between the staple
released version and all my built
versions right so noop noop a new
function page right so it asked me the
name of the function so it's going to be
e Thais super awesome function yeah this
is what it does for me right and so it
put up the name you go here it has all
the metadata and it's already saved in
the right place yeah if I had known
about this I well let's just say that
this meeting could go on for two more
hours and it's already worth the time
investment Roger should probably speak
up if this is the feature he exploits or
not because I think there were reasons
and that we didn't just make this
default forever I I didn't know about it
and I just saved them to the name that
need to be saved too but I assumed that
it figured out metadata and so on
whatever it needed now I see constant
commits from dqa
after pages are the future eyes Dov
adding missing metadata yep okay so let
me just walk through what that was okay
so what you're suggesting is people set
up a PAC --let they're the basis of
their packet repository right so they
have some say some git repo which is
padlet right well actually they might
want the base for their whole pack let
their old whole personal collection of
pack.lets I don't know whether they want
it for a specific Pacolet okay leather
way they set up the base
and then given that um you know Bob's
purple page whenever you say symbol it
would ask you what's the name of the
symbol you type it in then it creates a
page like we just saw that seems
eminently reasonable to me I mean we've
been doing that for years well we've
been doing it for system because that's
what we do at Wolfram we create a system
functions I know and whenever we have to
do it for something other than system
it's a huge mess indeed and we're people
let's let's let's talk about that for a
second okay so given so what happens is
you use one of the purple pages when you
start see one of the things that that is
tricky is the lightweightness or not of
starting a project so you know your
average IDE when you say new it comes up
with this whole well what are you trying
to make you know name the project etc
etc etc right and by the way those
projects presumably go into a default
directory am i making sense so we should
do the same thing I mean that is if it
says okay I'm starting a new pack light
purple page starting a new pack light
presumably on that purple page there
should be a field there that says what's
the name of this packet that you're
starting as soon as you press somehow
mm-hmm see what's nice with the function
repositories as I have proto function
repository pages in all kinds of random
directories yeah I you know it eclipse
does this where it you know eclipse
really wants you to put all of your
projects in one directory and it really
deeply frustrates me and as part of the
reason I don't use Eclipse a lot that's
okay it's not how I roll I like the idea
that the purple notebook can just sort
of float and it can have tentacles
reaching all over the place and then
when you hit the deploy button it
packages it all up into a nice layout
well so that I'm good with but that's
different from what Stephen was just oh
yeah I don't think that's what I think
that the purple notebook should sit in
some particular place for any given
Pacolet as defined by a purple notebook
that sits in some particular directory
and then everything associated with that
padlet gets built in that directory by
default so in other words different
packets can go in all kinds of different
places but within a single Pacolet
you've got a particular directory stuff
right and and when you say build let's
let's be careful about our terminology
here because there are two sorts of
things we might be referring to there's
you know all of your source files your
authoring notebooks and your code that
you're authoring and such and then
there's the deployed area and you know
we might want these areas to
conventionally be close to one another
but I think but but but I think that the
you know the packet info files should be
close to the source source yes I agree I
was going to make this yes a patrick the
typical workflow for a packet developer
is that you're building or you're
authoring your packet you know layout it
mirrors the runtime layout of the packet
so that you can run the code and see the
behavior of this packet
while you're developing it I'm really
essential you know although of course
you know that mirror is kind of
imperfect you know and and this is
something that you know I mean I deal
with not using workbench but you know
where it's like well I mean you know but
what's in my layout is all the authoring
notebooks not the deployed it's not it
doesn't work for Doc and it kind of
falls down a little bit for library like
stuff to America's suggestion why not
there's a source tree that is defined by
the you know by the purple notebook okay
it's a directory defined by the purple
notebook it's subdirectories whatever it
is it's it's a mirror of a layout okay
but it is a source its source files in
that layout okay then maybe this is a
bad idea but but then one possibility is
in the local object store if you say
deploy locally it will deploy everything
to the local object store and hopefully
we can be smart and not redeploy things
that don't need to be redeployed and
then that is almost transparently
equivalent to saying deploy in the cloud
or you know deploy to the public packet
repository so I'm saying so in other
words you you can pre-flight okay you're
running the thing but with source
notebooks just like when you develop
stuff you know when we develop stuff we
often look at the source notebooks in
docu tools for a documentation page and
we're quite familiar with seeing the
source version of things that doesn't
look quite the same as the built version
although for example function repository
is a good example of something where we
have managed to make the source version
look closer to the built version which
is nice and it's sufficiently close that
you can reasonably guess what it's going
to look like right there are things like
tables they looked a lot different but
the information saw there in it it's
understandable yeah to be fair some of
that's just the time the source
notebooks for documentation the built
the original vision for built notebooks
I think looked a whole lot closer to the
source than they do now it's just that
that's diverged over the years and the
source never kept up right
okay well kind enough so my suggestion
would be this
the purple notebook defines a position
for a directory structure the if you say
so there are various deployment options
local cloud public right as soon as you
deploy to one of those things files are
copied hopefully with a minimum of
copying because we know creation dates
and things like this and that's how it
works and if you want to run it you know
in its deployed version if you want to
run it just you know just like in a
function repository building thing if
you're trying to run your you know as
you're developing version of the
function you just run it right there
based on you know hitting shift enter to
evaluate the definitions in your
function repository notebook so you do
the same thing with a packet system but
if you want to run it like gonna work it
doesn't work you don't yeah you might
have 50 source files here I mean you
have to have if you if you are editing
Wolfram language code and every time you
make one edit you want to see the sector
this you have to build the thing and
deploy it into a different direction oh
no no no listen listen if what you were
doing is you've got one function you
need to read if redefine that function
you just have shift enter and whatever
file you were working on okay that's one
thing you could do if you need to build
the whole thing if you need to see how
it deploys pack the palettes or
something like this no no I'm talking
about pure Wolfram language code what if
you have ten source files of Wolfram
language cry I understand you know
you're editing want you know if people
don't work out in notebooks in hey you
can't shift enter you have your code in
dari m5 fine then in that case you have
a button in the in the purple you know
Pacolet you know control file so to
speak that says re-evaluate rerun Reese
you know rerun definitions and you're
not gonna get away from that by the way
and when I do this and you know I mean
basically what I have to do is I have to
have to reevaluate everything you know
if you know I have to have the you know
the top-level package file open in a
notebook and then I just have to
reevaluate it again from scratch but but
by the way that it also would be good to
have cleared the definitions because
otherwise you'll get weird you know
pattern overrun you know thing well yes
yes it would be good but you know
doesn't the pack of info file have
enough information to be able to do that
no I mean what I think what you're
talking about is you know how do I
unload a package and that's something
that I don't think we've been able to do
well ever you know Todd this comes right
back to the conflict that you and I were
having earlier today to my extremist
view versus your less extremist view
about include definitions and things
like that no it's so we were having this
discussion and you know and and and I'm
not I'm not belittling Todd's view
because both are kind of reasonable view
points without sighs and downsides but
the referred to myself as an extremist
but so so my notion is that packets in
the packet repository and and so I'm not
here talking about a limitation on
packets generally I'm talking about a
limitation on packets which are accepted
in the packet repository in the in our
packet repository the community one that
that they should have no side effects
outside of their designated namespace
and you know they can burrow as deep as
they want inside their own namespace but
they can't do anything you know that
like redefine system symbols or adds
global symbols or anything like that not
allowed and it wasn't it a global action
to add something to the pellets menu so
I'm here I'm just talking about the
Wolfram language view yeah yes you're
right the the palettes menu I mean you
know we can have you know multiple
packets that have the same name black
shoes dollop off dollop ah well that's
that but that's what I'm saying you
don't get to do that
you don't get to add dollar paths period
the not not by virtue of just loading
your package now I mean it might be
different if you have a function in your
package that does something maybe but
not by virtue of just loading the
package though you don't get to do that
and the and the the reason I'm saying
that is because once you give that
ability to you know you give that
ability out now you have you open up a
world where you know you have to pack
lists each of which wants to attach
their own rules to Plus and Todd feels
that's a pretty valuable thing to be
able to have packets that attach rules
to Plus and my feeling is that that that
good old is not so I don't we do this
why don't we do this why don't you I
gotta get both of your points of view
yeah why don't we do this why don't we
have something where an important
declaration for a packet just like it's
you know for an app it's does it look at
your location or something or does it do
this or that that you're basically
declaring any external actions that the
Pacolet takes and so most packets the
preferred thing would be a packet has no
external actions but you know even
putting something in the palette menu
might be upset this sounds kind of
Android ish so so Android when you
install applications has you know you
know it has this security model where
you know you have to declare all of
these you know potential you know
security concern issues that your app
does and so that's open information for
people who are installing your app well
sounds not completely silly because I
mean you know it could very well be the
case that most of the time people have
zero side effect you know installations
but even putting something in the
palettes menu somebody might have
carefully crafted their palette menu you
know and they might be very upset that
something
inserts itself there without you know
it's like well that's a side effect oh
and and and and just to get back to the
original reason that I raise this was
because you raise the issue of why don't
we just have it kind of delete you clear
everything and start over from scratch
you can only clear everything if you
know what to clear and if you can make
the assumption that everything's in the
namespace then that's the thing you
could conceivably do so fine so then
then we could have a button that says
you know clear and rerun we have another
button that's you know in some kind of
pull down anything that says just rerun
don't try and clear we have another
button that says just clear don't try
and rerun and then that's in the you
know in the purple manifest file so to
speak um the I don't think we want this
notebook to take over the process of
Packer development right I mean people
develop overall facts in all sorts of
modes in their favorite editors and ID
ease with this layout and we want to
give them a tool that makes it easier to
start one from scratch say or to deploy
an existing one fine that this tool is
going to give them a bunch of
capabilities like rerun the definitions
clear the definitions and so on it's
sufficiently hopefully it's sufficiently
lightweight that most people will run it
and potentially that it can be provided
in an SDK form that can be integrated
into IDs see what I'm saying I mean in
other words if if your favorite IDE
could have this as a little kit that
could have a few buttons that do the key
things from the purple notebook we'd be
in great shape I mean I you know I will
certainly say you know my principle
experience here is is you know
developing get linked and there is
definitely a level of inconvenience to
you know every time I make a small
change that I basically have to quit and
restart the kernel rerun the you know
Pacolet directory ad or ad packs or
whatever that's all and
you know and then load everything again
I mean did this you know obviously you
know it's not so much that I gave up
development but it is there is a certain
level of inconvenience now that having
been said get linked you know there are
extra things involved with with
unloading and reloading because there's
a library like that potentially has to
be unloaded and reloaded right but okay
so listen listen what is wrong with my
proposal in other words we provide the
purple page and SDK versions of the
purple page that are a convenient way to
be the central sort of control point for
dealing with your Pacolet if you try to
launch a notebook from an SDK does it
launch desktop okay then fact that
notebooks are the documentation writing
interface that is correct that's correct
and if you really don't like that you
know you can use them in the cloud or
something like this but it's going to be
a notebook we're not gonna rewrite you
know the whole system for creating you
know documents right and if you you know
that I mean you know conceivably one day
you can have something where you import
markdown or something I don't know but
that's a separate problem not the
problem we're solving here right people
want to write our fully rich you know
notebook based documentation they write
it in notebooks which is a great medium
for doing it so okay so we're back back
to this again so then the idea would be
the purple page has let's see you can
you save it in a particular directory of
your own choice and that page needs to
be saved before you start creating
documentation pages if that page isn't
saved nothing will it just won't let you
create it'll complain if you try and
create a documentation page once that
saved it will be in some directory and
the directory that it's in would have a
little miniature version of our
directory
no distribution directories that would
get built in it as you put in
documentation pages from that purple
anchor page so to speak then if you want
to really see how this is going to work
you can deploy it locally to the local
object store globally to you know to
your cloud account blah blah blah say
you already have a file whether it's a
documentation notebook or a package file
or something and you want to include in
your new Placid does that immediately
get copied into this directory or only
want you to play it does it get copied I
don't know I mean the purple page could
have a button that says include this
file when you could just do it yourself
I mean you know where the directory is
this is assuming you know it's in that
directory look the file isn't connected
to your padlet project unless it's
mentioned in the Pacolet manifest which
is controlled by the purple page
manifest is it copied to the directory
or is it just a manifest listed wherever
it was I would say probably will be okay
for the manifest to list it but I'm not
sure the manifest is not going to point
to places I mean the packet info file is
not know the faculty manifest is hidden
in the metadata of the purple notebook
right now it could be just made more
transparent very complicated for users
it I think the typical workflow is that
I mean this is a sense you know you
created you want to create a new packet
so you you open up you pay one of these
files wears purple notebooks and then
you save it something directly that is
going to be the development directory
for your package I know so Baba's lotus
considering the case where you started
and you didn't think you were developing
a padlet and you have a bunch of files
and now you want to put them in a padlet
area and so I that there is an argument
that we just say okay if you want to do
that with our whole manifest system put
them in the same directory not too
difficult right or you're making a new
packet Pacolet you realize oh I need
this stuff from the last one
you know well realize you're Giles in
this too right so that's an issue
I don't want the whole you don't want a
dependency on that other packet you just
well you might want to break those are
reasonable things okay so fine so then
that that you've just argued why it has
to be the case that the the thing can
point to a foreign directory now if you
if you go modify that you know if you
get rid of the foreign directory then
when you go to deploy the thing all bets
are off right but though you can either
choose by hand it's not going to move
anything the only time it's going to
move something as when you do a
deployment great it's either going to
say it's very inconvenient have to have
a deployment step just should have a
packet that you can run no I we're not
saying that we're not saying that we
Todd we're not saying that it's just
you're just probably I we filed outside
of the directory has he assembled to
create a functioning packet no that's
not right one that's not right okay
that's not right they don't have to be
assembled at all and they're not
creating what you're doing is you have a
button in that purple notebook that says
run my definitions get my packet ready
so that in the session that I am
currently using the packet is as if
loaded okay that's one thing the second
case is deploy it to my local object
store so that I have something which
when I start a new session I can just
say I want that packet it loads in it's
all packaged properly for me first the
first case okay well I want to I want to
I want my system to act as if the packet
is installed yep this version yep
that I was that going to work if you
have a manifest that points the files
outside of the package because if your
packet isn't nothing it's nothing does
not have a layout somewhere on disk it
represents the actual runtime layout of
the packet then this step isn't going to
work no no it is going to work because
it's just going to be a button that says
run the definitions for this pack light
and it can run the definitions in either
a local file or some remote file
I think this is a diner it's a demon of
definitions it's not that is not a
suitable way to make a Pacolet behave as
if it's you know or why not you might
have a focus you might have you might
have palette or you might have a library
you might have some some some Java
classes you might have all sorts of
resources that are not going to be
enabled by pressing a button okay but
for the time being let's assume
everything that's copied into the
directory pointed to by the in which the
purple file you know which the purple
file refers to purple page refers to
okay I think that's fine let's do that I
mean I think that there's an argument
that we might want some remote
dependency possibility but let's not
worry about that if you think that's
difficult let's not worry about that
okay okay so um let's come back to the
original topic here which was actually
we've got a number of interesting
comments on our live stream here yes
Ethan is saying you wish there's a slim
diversion - tools that is precisely the
topic of our meeting um a build tool
like sea make or ant
well that's effectively what this
Pacolet thing is trying to do is it not
I don't know to what extent one can
connect I mean it's an interesting
question to what extent our release
engineering tools I don't know what
we're using Jenkins and all this I don't
answer it was all answer okay Oh
Jenkins is all and I mean actual is that
the derivative of what used to be UNIX
make files and things or is no no I mean
we entered a Java build library it's
it's a so it has manifest files and it
you know puts things in the right places
and so on it would be nice if our stuff
could plug into that so that somebody
could build a large system and have it
all work using whatever sort of build
tools they use and we are
you know just like you can call well
from script from a random shell file um
you know be able to call our you know
Pacolet building system from whatever
random you know overall build system
they're using I mean you can only do
that with ant there's already a Pacolet
task in ant and there's a there's a
Mathematica it's called because it's old
tasks and Anna's rubber lets you call
what the language from that so we do
have tools for calling Wolfram stuff
directly from ant and it's worth noting
that if you make a if you build a packet
with documentation in workbench that
documentation is built by launching an
ant at like by launching an ant process
that runs that does these things that
top is talking about and builds your
documentation and indexes it and
everything else so yeah I mean we don't
have any seeming integration for this
stuff it's something I've thought a
little bit about I don't know that's a
separate thing but I think that is an
important thing so that people can
script these things from essentially
shat of the shell that this is runnable
through Wolfram script for example or
something from the shell um okay but
let's come back to the original topic
here which is the creation documentation
okay so the from the purple page it is
now defined a directory so it has the
notion of you know make documentation
for a first symbol for example or in the
case of the main part of the purple page
make the shingle that will be the main
advertisement for this padlet in lists
of packets and so on
makes sense to everybody yes so I mean
so basically what we're saying is that
the purple page has an interface for
that you may open source pages right
your source pages and that saves them in
the right place it's out etcetera and
then there is a button in the purple
page that will handle building exactly
okay holding either locally or in the
cloud or wherever okay
makes sense to everybody anybody not on
board with this okay let's continue okay
so then the question is what does it
look like okay so what okay so building
a symbol page as you say here the
function repository is a reasonable you
know has a reasonable model for a simple
page um
well kind of I mean it's at the risk of
sounding a little tautological or
whatever you know that the toolbar is
good for writing functions repository
pages um you know it's what if you want
to link things yeah I understand that's
an issue what if you want to tag state
of things right I mean when you're doing
a packet you've got multiple function
pages some are currents some are not you
know well I think what we want to do is
the same future ization mechanism and
we've agreed to have an excluded cell
mechanism in the function of posit or e
which is the analog of you know which is
probably the public version of future
ization right but you would never future
eyes a whole page for the function
repository because then why are you
doing it right why are you sure right I
mean the mechanisms that we've developed
over the last three decades we might as
well reuse so I'm not arguing that but
I'm saying
right so one repo thing we have now is
all a bunch of tools within the notebook
itself within the templates itself but
right okay should we be talking about
the need for a standalone palette or not
okay Andre you're saying that you would
never future eyes the whole page I would
actually do that no I'm saying I would
never future eyes a whole function
resource page whole function resource
page right yeah a whole page yes yes and
so for that reason does it make more
sense to have those kinds of tools in
the standalone no not for that
not for that because I think the right
way to do that is that's just a
checkmark at the top you know is this an
excluded page is it not an excluded page
whatever for the page we don't want to
spend the whole pallet into the
wait wait wait wait wait wait that
obvious thing is much better to do on
the page than in some crazy palette you
know there should be a menu at the top
of the page that says is this page
inactive page or is an excluded page
it's really very simple that I just said
that I wanted stare into 10 different
menus not worrying about that we can we
can solve that that there will be there
will be palettes that you know hang
around this for doing specialized things
but I think we should try and put most
of it into toolbars on the page most of
the common stuff into toolbars on the
page because then we can store state of
the page in the state of that toolbar
like is an excluded page or not right
now you've raised the question of
cross-linking between these pages right
okay the good news is because everything
is in this directory see okay so one of
the issues is yes right I mean because
it's all in one directory we can do the
same auto linking that we do in our
system directories which is as soon as
you have a symbol name it goes and looks
does that symbol name exist in the
directory that you know is it in a place
on a guide page where it should exist in
that directory and it either becomes a
link or it becomes a proto link if that
page doesn't exist and indicates that
it's an error because the page isn't
linkable I mean though the symbol isn't
linkable yet does that make sense I mean
I think so but and and there yeah there
are a number of ways that we could
handle you know intra Pacolet linking
and I'm not suggesting that we handle
inter Pacolet linking but you know you
might have you will get you will may
well linking to setting aside inter
packets linking the system functions
exactly and e SE package functions
built-in pack like J link if you want to
link to a J link function okay so know
how far you wanna dig you give its
context and then you press link and it
turns into the right thing so your
safety concept like something click a
button and then you get a pop-up that
you have to fill out like a forum no not
really I mean
here's what I think it should do I think
you type in the name if it's really
obvious where that goes
if it you know if it obviously goes to a
system function if somebody's over
writing a system function you know that
because there is that Nate okay
here's what it should do it has a
directory within that package right it
knows the names of functions as
documented in that package okay
step one go to those if if they if it
exists they're probably just linked to
it okay if it doesn't exist there you
got to look in the system context if it
doesn't exist there you give a little
message that says where is it and you
can fill in the context if you know it's
in the J link to wreak on text then you
put J link backtick thing and it won't
write J link backtick thing of course
you know on your page it'll do something
more like what elegant than that but um
but that's how I would do it I think
it's really straightforward no I think
it would also be common or thing I think
is blinking to the Pacolet and that a
symbol within it fine so right and
similarly with the function repository
and things like that we've got to you
know linking to a function apposite or a
function we don't have a way to do that
I mean and to be clear some of these
things are things that I wish worked
right now in da key tools even exactly I
was just thinking that but I mean this
is we can make up a thing to make these
hyperlinks just like the new hyperlink
dialog has some ability to say what kind
of a target is this hyperlink going to
that's what we can do here if it's
obvious what the target is it can
automatically you know pick the target
if it isn't obvious it can ask you and
if you want to pick it yourself have
some mechanism for doing that okay so
let's keep going here um guide pages and
we just need a way of making a guide
page um it's as simple as that and we
need a way so one of the things is the
cross linking of guide pages and right
now I mean what we've done for the last
however many years is we have a single
directory of guide pages and that's been
enough for our whole system so I think
it's gonna be enough for people's back
let's - it's a single directory of guide
pages the guide pages have names
link to the named guide page and you can
okay so we have a little bit of fancy
footwork to do with renaming of pages
and I think we could repeat that in in
this system we simply have a you know a
button that says you know tools or
something and one of those tools is a
renaming tool and that renaming tool
could be local to a particular file then
it just says rename the symbol and then
it goes in and it'll have to figure out
you know how to set up the renaming and
if it would be a luxury feature to
rename that symbol in other files you
know to go find where it where its
backlinks are and go rename it another
files that I would consider to be a
luxury but it would be a nice thing to
be able to do well in general it would
be you know the more general version of
being able to track down everything is
having some method as part of the build
step you know some kind of linting thing
that looks for dead links mm-hmm yes
that's a good idea too which is what we
have and andhaka tools okay yeah so um
but but what's in doc your tools I think
is only on the build side not on the
authoring side so we get reports out of
the build system but we can't like you
know scan this scan a page okay so one
of the short-term things is making guide
pages for function repository functions
which is a test run of making guide
pages for and the kind of the idea for
that is for right now those guide pages
will be things that people can put they
can publish in their own cloud accounts
we don't yet have a repository of guide
pages for the function repository
although that may come um and we'll have
to see what people produce there um but
I think it could very well be that
people could for example link them to
their you know shingles on Wolfram
community and things like that the the
guide page of interesting functions that
they've created or other people have
created that they use is gone I mean it
reminds me of sort of the early websites
that people created where people would
say you know my convenient you know they
would have their public facing home page
and they would also have their
convenient links on it
um but in the case that okay so a
short-term thing is the as a guide page
creation page that will look will be
basically a local you know thing like
this right and that's that's underway is
it not
and Bob was working on that is that
correct or was it Brian who is working
on that we are bus we're gonna
collaborate not a lot of work summed up
in a short term I don't think it all
dragged on okay but I mean so then the
question you you guys need to come up
with you know in the guide you know in
this tab which things here of this giant
list are actually useful yeah probably
like the first six buttons that's
probably about it frankly okay I mean
one thing that is important we've talked
about how these links work you know when
you do refer to something funky like an
entity for instance you need to make
sure that there's a way of saying I want
to reference a weird kind of thing which
kind of thing is it okay now type it in
and it will be tagged correctly yeah
right now it's it does some guessing and
it's not always accurate right I think
we need to give it a way to make sure it
can be accurate and I mean the other
thing that goes wrong on guide pages is
you know detailed formatting of unusual
things like slash at being naked Leon a
guide page and so on and we probably
need some escape valve for dealing with
you know literally specified formatting
that make sense
I think so yeah okay yeah that's okay um
uh wait wait
and maybe you guys talked about and I
missed it because I got distracted but
are we really saying we're gonna add a
file new repository menu item for guide
page creation well we were just about to
talk about okay okay well alright then
what's wrong with that it's too
specialized for that prominence in our
menu system the menu system I know I
think it's useful because I think for
example I've been building a guide page
for you know this physics project thing
where you know it's a guide page with a
bunch of function repository functions
together with a bunch of built-in
functions and it is a useful page for me
personally and hopefully for other
people in in due course but why wouldn't
we have a file new documentation type of
thing and then you you you get the
purple one or whatever no no because you
don't need the purple one
this guide page thing is independent of
purple ism alright it's independent of
making a pack light there's a there's a
useful concept of making a guide page
that could be just a guide page of
system functions it's just a useful
thing to have it's a useful formula
where where's it deployed I mean you can
deploy it it's the exact same story as
all the other deployments you can deploy
it locally you can deploy it to the your
cloud account and we don't why have you
deployed locally how do you how do you
open it up how do you bring it up in the
help system I would assume that what we
would do is under the okay so we didn't
discuss that but presumably it would
attach itself to your um to your route
guide page I'm sorry so this is so this
is documentation for one is is that what
we're talking about here bespoke bespoke
guide page yes yes we're talking about
that for one case right which opened I
mean for one person is what is right and
outside the context of docu tools and
or documentation tools right it's it's
it's I would like a guide page of things
I think are cool and I want it for
myself
yeah oh you want to put it on the you
know you want to link it to your
community account or you want to give it
to your research group or you want to
you know give it to whatever but the
spoke and artisanal job in the parlance
of our test
yeah that's I mean it's I to me it seems
like it's it's like taking the
favoriting system and saying here you
can do more with it but you have to
invest a lot more into no it's going to
be very easy to write these I mean the
whole point is but you have to write it
sure yes you have to write it I don't
have to write favorite so I can just
click to add something to I know but but
the favorites list doesn't give you
structure in the way that a guide page
does I mean I never use these I mean you
can get some structure I mean you know
web browsers no I don't organize things
and you know sub menus or whatever
that's so I never use that I'm you know
like I have a personal home page which
is built from notebooks that is you know
that has structure that allows me to
find things because otherwise I have you
know 200 links and I can never find
anything and yes I know people do do
things with favorites you know maybe my
complicated and I got you got it links
to but they're organized if my favorites
okay well okay in any case I think it is
useful we've got this mechanism for
guide pages which works well I think
it's important to give people and we're
going to need this anyway because we're
gonna need that guide page authoring
system for pack.lets repository item
it's not it's not why it has to go under
there I don't know we might have to find
another place to put it okay we might
want to rename that top-level thing I
don't know that's not the most important
thing right now and this is part of what
yes I mean it you know it may just be a
name that we can talk about later but
this is part of what confused me earlier
cuz you were referring to it as a
repository thing and I'm thinking
wait are you publishing this to the
function repository say it say so maybe
we want a separate tag here that says
you know documentation items and
separate from repository item so yeah I
like that better I mean cuz it bothers
me that you would have such a guide page
thing and not have other documentation
types available the same way which are
likely to be just as interesting to
people okay fine
where is where is computational I say
gonna go it would be just on that list
somewhere just it isn't under set menu
yeah but to emphasize Andres points yeah
I mean I I could imagine you know
someone just doing one off bits of
documentation maybe you know they don't
want to publish you know to the function
resource site maybe there something
right and they don't want to publish to
the they don't I don't even making a
function repository item they just want
to make the page that is documenting
something completely different
yeah I agree so why not give them that
and it would be modeled directly on the
function repository page the only
question is what the pre-flight
mechanism is and so on and how much
checking is done okay fine so let's
imagine there's a documentation tab here
that okay let's talk about the other
types of pages here okay so let's go
okay there is tutorials now and somebody
asked in the livestream about both
tutorials and workflow okay fine but but
we are alighting tutorials right and
that's an internal remnant yes I
understand but I'm saying for what we
are providing for people in the outside
world there's a what what are we
alighting them into I mean where are you
lighting them into tech notes and
monograph I mean tutorial I understand
that I understand but somebody wants to
author a tech note how do they do it
right and that's that is under the
documentation you know new file new
documentation we could perfectly well
have a thing that says tech note right
I'm sorry I'm sorry can can somebody
just give a
a 10-second overview of the difference
between tech notes and monographs okay
Oh between took miss Monica I was gonna
say between tech notes and tutorials a
tech note is a tutorial it is written
the exact same way and it has the same
kind of content it's just a tech note is
a tutorial that's not a monograph now
the difficulties not hardly I know but
give examples okay so the the advanced
dissolve Docs
that's a monograph it goes oh it's like
closer to my paper yeah it's a lot of
textbook formulas it doesn't talk about
necessarily just how to use dissolve in
Wolfram language its what is a
differential equations in 20 why is this
a tutorial yeah
the nd solve stuff is not converted over
it looks like okay so there we go so
that's a monograph okay so that's a
monograph and it's big and this is
hundreds of pages long but a tech note
is similar but it just has a somewhat
different format and it is typically you
know I don't know couple to a couple of
tens of pages long and you know techno
can have a table of contents like that I
mean a tech note would be like the image
processing the image processor much
processing tutorials which are very much
here is here are the image processing
functionalities available in the Wolfram
language here's how you use them or the
intro to dynamic advanced dynamic sure
yeah yeah okay or the jailing dog yeah
the vast number of old tutorials of
becoming tech notes there are vast
majority of old story is becoming tech
notes only a few are monographs okay
Ethan our live stream is complaining
that something is so ugly
please use ma Tech I don't know what's
the ugly which which part is the ugly
part this thing you know this is kind of
ugly it's too small
ah sigh Brian that's for you really does
look kind of ugly you know why it's so
small
yeah fine I mean it's just that's a
stylesheet issue sure don't Orange title
ball and on the early I think he may be
referring to the earlier page you are on
the monograph you know yeah there you go
I know it's not actually the current
design that's been refreshed a little
bit it's just not implemented in product
yet alright that is quite ugly I agree
um but any case I mean that the point of
a monograph is it's like you know it's
like a textbook type thing as opposed to
a tech note which is a which could be
something like you know how to set up
your you know installation of unity so
that it can interact with unity link ok
well that was about the 240 second
version of the 10 second thing I asked
for but thank you okay ok let's look at
the other what what is the M tab well
that's something marketing okay which by
the way will also be relevant for people
making packets for the repository in the
end maybe some form of it but our
marketing pages are that's what's on em
tab is probably we probably want
something else I don't know I mean
that's that's those are the things for
creating the whole new end version
whatever things right okay so these need
some modernization where is the workflow
workflow pages I would not expect any of
these other than workflows to get into
what we're providing
yeah and workflows I think are probably
beyond the scope of version one I mean
look at like the annotation palette
we're talking about some serious stuff
here like click that second black button
under workflow pages open annotation
palette
I mean it's magnificent it's really cool
it's really cool but we need to be able
to get this packaged up and shipped for
you know and I'm not sure this is
a little bit beyond the scope of a
version one it depends if it's already
this was built fairly recently it's
fairly modern it's possible you can just
lift it you know pick it up and ship it
it's not clear that this is you know
it's been pretty widely used within the
company it's not really
I don't even know how to use it I and
I've not aware of any training
opportunities on this it was my
understanding that it was a pretty small
group of people that was using this John
it's done within your group by Chris
because he was the first one like one
other person and that's all I know
pinked up and produced errors to do with
B spline functions that's not
encouraging that was a that as a bug of
some kind I pressed the big down arrow
and produced a B spline error message
sure it's the I I agree with John the
learning curve for writing workflows is
non-trivial and that's why it not all
and like just like you saw you know you
just click the button and it exploded on
you um there's some cleaning and some
documentation help you know our meta
documentation and and that's part of the
reason that I never pushed on this
because I was always led to believe well
it's kind of a tower of stuff right now
and where we're trying to you know clean
it up so that it's for you know look at
this look at this is even got
documentation for the documentation
maker I mean I'm telling you this is
pretty well developed stuff and it may
be that we should put it out there you
know in the world of packet repositories
you know putting this out there as
something that people you know as a
packet the people can make use by
putting it out there within the company
it has a learning curve no question John
I mean for example I've never offered
one of these things I mean even though I
had sort of imagined that I would it is
a little complicated
and you have to actually do it enough to
remember you know I mean that the
results are very nice but you know it's
it's you know it's like I mean right
there's a lot of a lot of detail here
okay in any case are there other any
other documentation types that we should
be discussing formats might be something
that other people want a document as
well in that even our live stream is
saying publish these workflow tools in
Wolfram github.com I seem sensible to me
to do that I mean why not do that it's
you know if they turn out to be unusable
by people so be it but it seems to me
that they're pretty well-developed
things I mean but this probably lives on
top of daki tools is that right Brian I
don't think so I think this is
standalone the annotations well I mean
the the template is certainly a part of
daki tools is certainly the
infrastructure underneath this I'm not
saying that it couldn't be decoupled but
there I mean it is run from docu tools
so that there are some assumptions yeah
and to understand you know as far as
github you know I'm always a big
advocate for putting stuff on github but
you don't want to put stuff on github
that people don't undergo can't figure
out how to actually use how to even
install and so that's when I stopped
stuff from going on github it's often
about that another kind of page would be
like a top-level Pacolet documentation
page but that's what we talked about
having in the purple page right there's
a purple at the body of the first page
right now is basically in fact that info
dot app but what we're saying is I think
that purple page should be the central
place where you build the shingle for
your Pacolet yeah but I imagine it would
lon it could launch another type of if
you want a documentation page that would
define the body of the shingle if you
want to put like a really cool
visualization that comes out your back
so your point is that I mean okay that's
fine you have two different places you
know one is the sort of build script
part of it and the other is the shingle
part of it that's an it and it's
basically like another documentation
page that's marketing I don't disagree
yeah well so but back to the list of Oh
things here what other things can be
created like shadi mentioned formats you
can define your own formats right yes
Unicode
can you define your own interpreters
entities I guess you can do entities
right yes you absolutely can do it let's
just go down this embedding format oh
gosh
those are yeah I mean those eventually
people will be able to do that um entity
pages yes that one is perfectly
reasonable because that's for an entity
store that's documenting a piece of an
entity store sure that's something we'll
need um interpreter pages probably less
so immediately because I don't think
that's something that's used at audible
at this time external program pages I
don't know it might be a courtesy to
give that to people because they may
have external programs that they want to
include in this documentation framework
doesn't seem critical device pages same
story service pages that framework I
don't know what the status of that
framework becoming the repository is
does anybody know here it ready to be
when we prioritize it we can make it
happen sort of thing I don't think we I
think we what we want it to be its own
repository we don't want to be part of
the backup repository or so I don't
think we need that
no no but it'll need it it'll need a way
to make documentation pages for it well
but I think you saying I see what you're
saying yeah it'll be a service the
service page will have will be a self
documenting page because they'll have a
definition notebook exactly I saw let me
amend my original question what of these
things would a person typically could a
person typically develop as part of a
packet entity storm yeah and I think
formats potentially as well yes I agree
blockchain pages we need a button
invented cryptocurrency you know
a new cryptocurrency no that's going out
of style
now about that button you get a few
million dollars a section that's not
here that has been discussed actually
very recently that it's going to show up
soon message pages that's something that
you know yes I want to document their
error messages that's you know that
would be useful I mean there's some
things here that a much fancier look
let's just go down this list database
connection pages that's clearly
technical and complicated form pages yes
what is an example page
those are featured example pages
obsolete should be gone source pages
that is like data notes like
astronomical data source character pages
again not something that's user edible
is it no no it's not I mean except you
can point to a piece of Unicode and
document a piece of Unicode but it's not
something people care about right now
fast intro pages in elementary intro
that those are both interesting
documentation forms those are pretty
nice I mean the two but again out of the
scope of this discussion guides compiled
type pages C language pages wow that's
wild
that's one of those net encoder pages
let's Excel function pages I think the C
language pages is that supposed to be WS
so that's where that is that's I been
looking for it for years yes yes I
actually we put it yeah you have been
looking for it for years we put it in in
the last maybe six months per your
request
okay requests too but yes thank you now
it's an important library link see page
also does work but because library link
is a Pacolet it doesn't autosave so what
is that what is this for that this is
what what is this understand is this
relevant to users with their packets if
they create library link components to
their packets
possibly you know I mean it's yeah it's
C function you're documenting C
functions that may live inside of a
library I mean you know frankly my you
know I mean my view is that the
idiomatic way to do this is to wrap it
it's wrap a C function and a good
wolfson language interface and talked
about the Wolfram language interface
fine okay anything else we need to go
over here I think well we didn't get to
classify and predictor somebody might
put one of those in the back that Mirza
just like the built in named ones well
that's how the built in name know that
mind know that there's no reason to put
that in a padlet because you can put it
in the neural net repository right is
that right no right good but I think
that is something look the fact is in
the net report in the neural net
repository you're putting networks in
there some of these classifiers have
wrapping that goes beyond networks and
there is an argument that we could have
a you know classifier repository that
would mostly just typically access the
neural net repository unless people have
a different way of making a classifier
it's an interesting question it's a
reasonable question I mean to be able to
have that be user extensible does seem
like a reasonable thing um that's a
question fashion and so on go ahead an
entity in function repository that uses
the net marlowe and does what you what
do you want it to do and then that's how
we can get documents well sure but but
the question is whether classify of a
string should be able to do this right
um okay
anything else here
Ethan keeps on emphasizing that that it
would be a good test to take our
workflow package and publish it in the
packet repository and see if it works
yeah I mean it's a I meant to respond to
this earlier but we got sidetracked you
had said something about the you know
all this stuff having to be a part of
the system I think if we have a good
repository it doesn't even be a part of
the system at all you know it's it can
be the first thing you install if you
want to write something as for the
repository well I think the repository
and whatever yeah okay all right so we
have a poem I mean I mean you know among
other things you know I mean internally
the doc utils Pacolet updates really
super frequently and you know it might
be nice to you know kind of you know if
we have a version of that that's on
that's on the packet repository to be
able to track that and even be able to
you know have a change log for it yes I
and I but we want built-in abilities to
create packets we don't want to have to
have people have a meta Pacolet to
create you know have a packet to create
packets we want to be able to have
people just open up the system and start
creating packets well I'm not saying
that that's terrible but I disagree that
there
required okay I think that I think it's
highly desirable I think it's what we
should whether that under the hood works
by operating with some underlying
Pacolet that's fine that's its
prerogative but I think that the I mean
I mean this this comes to a larger more
existential disagreement that you and I
have that that you know you kind of want
to scour the world and and throw
everything into the core system and and
I know I'm ten more toward the you know
let's have the core system be able to
access everything in the world and make
it really easy to extend but it doesn't
have to be inside the core system yeah
every time I try and access something I
was just trying to use the Unity link
for example right which is just like
it's like oh the unity system doesn't
start up oh it crashes on the Windows
machine that is the only one I have
that's connected to a VR headset because
VR stuff doesn't run properly on my Mac
blah blah blah blah blah that's yeah
anyway the UM that sounds like a good
reason not to have it in the core system
so that it's not crashing in Mathematica
every time you that wasn't my takeaway
anyway um sorry let me see there was one
other point yeah I just wanted to
emphasize this point about being able to
make SDKs for other IDs is that a real
thing I think it should be a real thing
I'm just like we're putting that it
depends on the well clips I mean what
I'm saying is just like we're providing
syntax colouring for IDs or you know
there's a sophisticated thing done for
at Ellijay and so on just like we are
you know providing tools to help with
things like syntax colouring I think we
should provide sort of plugin tools to
help external IDs to be able to make use
of the documentation system and so on
alright but I think the way to do that
is to
you know and integration and see make
integration so that all the IDS which
speak these common dialects and just
that's fine that's realistic that's just
fine I mean I don't know enough about
how these IDs I set up inside
well Visual Studio speaks see me the
Eclipse speak see make and doesn't some
day Apple will figure it out and in half
Xcode join the game yeah but Apple
really doesn't allow very much automatic
integration into Xcode so right I
remember I can't we submit your notes to
the north at repository you absolutely
can I mean I don't know what the state
of having what is the state of having a
user accessible definition notebook for
the new on that repository we need to
circulate breath I was gonna say we
refactored things for the data
repository notebook and so neural net is
within reach but we do need to talk to
them to chain learning group and see
what needs to go in it and so on and so
forth well but it should be easier to do
now that we've refactored
the function repository lessons into the
data repository and I'm more generalized
approach sounds good
yeah we there are user created nets in
there but it's more of a contact us on
the feedback form and let us know you
have something sort of process but but
we intended to have and should now have
a a you know a definition notebook for
that yep but if you have something great
and you want us to publish it just use
the contact form we'll we'll get back to
you and make it happen mm-hmm
sounds good all right okay sounds like
we have a path forward thanks all thanks
to folks on the livestream thank you for
your comments